who were the biggest pranksters there is
no better bonding experience
than by pranking one another right well
that seems to be the case between
hollywood actors at least
you've got to really prank someone just
like a family amongst a cast
there's always a master prankster
wrecking havoc on set
luckily for us these pranks usually end
up being hilarious
can you guess which actor was pranked
with a fart machine in front of his
crush
in this video we're exploring the best
of the best
you are so funny go ahead be funny yeah
all right i will
jennifer lawrence and josh hutcherson
became the best of friends on the set of
the hunger games
he's my rock but that was all thrown out
the window when it came to their prank
wars it's for fun
they had a full life-sized dummy of one
of our tributes that had gotten killed
by a tracker jacker
and basically it's all swollen and
gnarly looking and mangled
and jennifer was out of her trailer so i
took the dummy and put it inside her
bathroom in her
trailer the dummy he's referring to was
used for glimmer's tracker jacker scene
and jen was terrified i'm in my trailer
and open the bathroom door and scream
and my friend grabs me and had to say
it's fake it's fake it's fake i hate him
having a crush on someone is
embarrassing enough but add a fart
machine into the mix and it makes things
10 times worse just ask daniel radcliffe
really really funny and for you alan
rickman and michael gambin played the
most hilarious prank on dan while
filming the prisoner of azkaban
check it out we enter completely our own
world
the worst part is dan had just asked to
have his sleeping bag move next to the
girl he'd been crushing on at the time
awkward millie bobby brown and noah
schnapp
are the pranking duos to watch out for
on set of stranger things
however when it comes to gait and
matarazzo millie took the lead
gaetan started receiving some
interesting phone calls from unknown
numbers
is this dusty buns turns out it was just
his co-star
listen to him reenact the hilarious
conversation
wrong number you're like we're meant to
be together she's like i see you and i'm
like
no for this catching fire prank josh
hutcherson was just the co-conspirator
it was all jeffrey wright who plays bt
when it came to jennifer lawrence's very
surprising oscar present
just listen to what went down i went to
the pet store
um and found about 200 crickets poor
jennifer lawrence was just trying to do
her job but she couldn't escape her
scheming co-stars
yeah yeah it was very funny if you
caught the wear the miller's bloopers
you might already know what prank we're
talking about while shooting a scene
where they're driving in an rv
jennifer aniston and the cast were
supposed to be singing tlc's waterfalls
however during one take jennifer got the
biggest surprise
no one told her here that this take was
gonna be this way
kj apa didn't just stick to one person
with his shenanigans
he traveled around the entire set of
riverdale pranking the cast and crew
with what they thought was a cup of
very hot liquid ashley murray did not
seem very pleased with him
but he still posted all of the footage
to his instagram story anyway
instagram's a scary place there's
nothing stronger than brotherly love
and by that we mean tom holland getting
his brother harry a part in spider-man
no way home
and then pranking him during his scene
if harry wasn't
in my life i wouldn't have made it here
tonight harry holland's scene in the
upcoming spider-man film requires him to
be upside down
and tom said in the beginning of the day
i was like
making the takes extra extra long just
to see how long it would take before he
blacked out
charltoe copley learned one thing on the
set of maleficent
never push angelina jolie past her
comfort level
the day after charlton had been pushing
angelina to improv during a scene
he walked into his trailer to meet his
new friends two ravens who were in the
middle of ravaging his space
that was just like oh my god charlton
knew better than to try and get back at
her
there's no bigger fan of batman than
superman at least ben affleck made it
seem that way when he was filming dawn
of justice
alongside henry cavill one day henry got
to his trailer to see that someone had
given it a little makeover
look at the perfect tour of his revamped
trailer ben gave us
i think it's much better this way during
the big trial scene in season 4 of game
of thrones
the 200 extras on set got the
performance of a lifetime
peter dinklage and nikolai koster waldow
dancing
the extras applauding and shouting we
were going all the way down
however their little stunt didn't go
over great with the crew
and actually caused filming to get a
little awkward that day
it was it was incredibly embarrassing
there was
no napping on set for joseph naufahu on
the set of game of thrones
at least without the risk of getting
your face painted with caramel by amelia
clark
she put caramel fudge all over my
fingers all over my costume
and she was about to feed it to me but i
woke up
of course amelia thought the whole
situation was hilarious
working with amelia was amazing jackson
rathbone made the ultimate sacrifice to
be in the twilight films
dye his hair blonde however peter
faccinelli thought making the situation
even more daunting would be hilarious
so he enlisted eddie gothegi to pull the
ultimate prank call
he called and said hey this is susie
from the production office
we just want to tell you that we're
dying your hair back to brown because we
don't like the blonde hair
which i fought for by the way the worst
part was jackson shared the news with
his manager who was so relieved and said
she hated the blonde hair
things got awkward when they found out
it was all a prank
woody harrelson got a little morbid with
his hunger games prank
he enlisted his makeup artist to make
him look as if he had just been in a bad
motorcycle accident
the director sent him straight to the
hospital and woody decided to take the
prank
even further with liam hemsworth i
called liam and told him to come to the
hospital to pick me up
but i made the name up and of course
there was no such place
he's a lot of fun hilarious guy jonah
hill was ecstatic when he found out he'd
be getting a golf cart while filming
moneyball
however for brad pitt it was the perfect
opportunity to pull some pranks
much to the shock of jonah brad is the
prank master
every time i turn on my wandmobile full
volume in blasts
wake me up before you go no matter how
many times jonah hill tried to get back
at him
brad pitt always won everyone knows
i'm the tall one you're the short one
dominic monaghan and billy boyd had no
idea they were being pranked when they
were given revised scripts of the lord
of the rings
that let them know their characters mary
and pippin wouldn't be wearing as many
clothes as they thought
the script revealed that their
characters needed to preserve their body
heat by
cuddling naked millie bobby brown didn't
just show off her pranking expertise
on the set of stranger things she took
all that talent and brought it over to
godzilla
michael doherty and i we teamed up
together to prank one of her pranks
included putting rats in jackson
junior's freezer
and another included putting poop in
thomas middle ditch's toilet
who knew millie had such a dark side i
had to bring the youth to the set
chris hemsworth is all about vandalism
when it comes to giving his avengers
cast mates posters makeovers
and he isn't afraid to show it he
recorded the entire process and posted
it to instagram for the world to see
the cast took the prank in stride and
some even admitted to taking their
poster home as a memory
it's impossible not to take a little
piece home while filming american hustle
bradley cooper and christian bale knew
jay law was terrified of cemeteries
yes it's me you know so when they found
out that they would be filming at one
an inside source says bradley and chris
got the prop guys to carve a fake
tombstone of her name
and put it on set jen freaked out until
she realized the tombstone had the date
april 1st on it
thank god april fools hunger games and
game of thrones clashed when amelia
clark and sam clafland teamed up for
their film
me before you but on top of her acting
skills amelia also brought her pranking
techniques
i put fish in his socks and a fart
machine in his wheelchair
i don't know how this is allowed not to
worry though
sam got his revenge by stealing all the
furniture out of her trailer
with that one you know poor sam claflin
just can't catch a break
while filming catching fire josh
hutcherson made his trailer a very
stinky situation i was like i farted
he had this bottle of the best way to
describe it is as
skunk poo not actual skunk poo but it
stank and he rifled through my trailer
and decided to put it on a tissue and
put it in my trash
i was living a dream basically it stunk
up his whole
trailer on set of the pirates of the
caribbean johnny depp and penelope cruz
made a bed that resulted in the actress
coming to set
in some very interesting attire she had
lost the bet which meant she had to
strut her stuff
dressed as hanky the christmas poo from
south park
yeah it was kind of it was kind of great
he was on the floor
laughing and crying and he took a
thousand pictures of me which i hope
never come to light but of course now
that i've said it i'm sure they will
appear somewhere
while on set of the kissing booth joey
king captured the moment she played the
most classic prank on her co-star joel
courtney
she did apologize to joel on instagram
but then again she couldn't have been
that sorry if she shared it on social
media
no matter how mad you are at your best
friend you have to forgive them
if they give you ice cream noah
centineo's winks
had all the power while filming to all
the boys
but that's because the cast had an
inside prank going on that whenever
someone would wink at them
they'd have to slowly fall to the floor
until another co-star touched their
shoulder
even if they were in the middle of a
scene those were my pranks
kernan shipka and lucy davis had been
planning the ultimate prank for two
years
and finally got it done shut up
get out of here they rallied their
co-stars together and set them up for
fake interviews
can you can you give us any spoilers
hearing you want to tell them the last
scene
oh my god and the end product was
hilarious
just look at gavin's face i was like for
real is this guy for real
to his surprise tom holland arrived on
the set of a marvel movie only to find
out that the back of the actor's chair
had been cut out and placed onto a prop
toilet instead
tom still has no idea who played this
prank on him
but we're thinking it might be anthony
mackie who has admitted to pulling a lot
of pranks while filming
i'm a grown man i've been paying taxes
for 24 years
who knew how epic some of these onset
pranks could be
what we're gathering is the more pranks
on set the better chemistry is between
the cast members
who do you think deserve the title of
the ultimate prank master
thanks for watching